a fire destroys a mobile home inside
fire crews found two bodies this
happened this morning near nellis and
vegas valley jeremy j ford has more
tonight after speaking with neighbors
what we know thus far is around 9 15 a.m
an individual knocked on the door of
fire station 27 to report a mobile home
engulfed in flames
units arrived to find heavy fire and
smoke coming from the mobile home
crews then began putting out the fire
and evacuating neighboring homes after
the fire was extinguished fire crews
found two people dead inside
i spoke to neighbor jeannie sukov who
tells me what she saw my neighbor next
door here called and told me that her
husband had seen a house that her house
might be on fire and could i go out and
look so i came from the back of my house
into the living room into my big window
and saw this huge fire across the street
behind me
just blazing and at that time the
metro had everything sectioned off and
they had the fire trucks all out there
it was quite horrific the flames were
extremely high i just hope and pray that
people especially this time of year and
always
are just extra careful
and the fire is currently under
investigation jeremy j ford live
local now